[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans ce qu'ils mag
alors nous sommes aujourd'hui à la gare
de saint quentin en yvelines en
compagnie de jean baptiste à monique
bonjour alors monsieur jean baptiste à
monique vous êtes le maire de villepreux
et vous êtes également vice président de
saint quentin en yvelines et délégué des
transports et des mobilités durables
exactement alors justement on va en
discuter aujourd'hui quelle est la place
des mobilités durables ici à saint
quentin en yvelines alors aujourd'hui en
tout cas sur saint quentin en yvelines
vous savez nous on aime à parler de
bouquets de services de mobilité
c'est-à-dire que nous avons cette gare
ferroviaire nous avons 80 lignes de bus
90 lignes de bus pardon est évidemment
que nous avons souhaité avancer sur la
question des mods actifs et des
mobilités douces il faut savoir que
depuis 2010 9 l'usagé du vélo a augmenté
de 39% et donc nous avons nous sur notre
territoire déjà 420 km du tir est
recyclable mais il faut accompagner
cette pratique notamment pour des
raisons aussi de réchauffement
climatique de sobriété et de trouver des
solutions de déplacement pour tous les
saint quentinois et nous avons juste
derrière nous la vélostation qui est un
des outils de cette mobilité qui est le
vélo qui doit devenir une mobilité du
quotidien la vélostation propose 170
vélo à la location c'est aussi 280
places de stationnement c'est un atelier
de réparation à un atelier de
maintenance et de nombreuses animations
aussi qui sont proposés sur les
différentes communes de
l'intercommunalité
alors justement je vous propose de
découvrir la vélostation en images
la vélostation de saint quentin en
yvelines propose trois service books la
location de vélos la réparation des lots
est également le stationnement sécurisé
pour la location de vélos nous avons 170
vélo 150 vélos classiques 10 vélos à
assistance électrique et 10 vélos
pliants pour un vélo classique nous
sommes à 132 euros à l'année
l'accès à nos consignes sécurisait se
fait uniquement par le passe navigo et
l'abonnement annuel est de 30 euros
répond parfaitement aux attendus plus en
plus c'est économique c'est pas très
cher et donc c'est hyper pratique pour
tout le monde la sphère deux hommes que
tu lis et je trouve ça très bien parce
qu'on l'utilisé 3 canal pour mon vélo
électrique en haïti ce cas c'est tout
simplement génial
donc dès que j'ai su que ça existe je me
suis inscrit des jeux l'utilisent tous
les jours ça me révolution un petit peu
la vie dont je dépends plus des horaires
de bus et en plus je fais un peu de fard
saint quentin en yvelines a décidé de
mettre un nouveau service en place sous
forme de mobilis qui se déplacera sur
l'ensemble des communes du territoire ce
service proposera l'ensemble des
services de la vélostation donc à la
fois de la location des réparations mais
également le retrait de les vélos c'est
un enjeu important pour saint quentin en
yvelines parce que c'est une demande des
usagers justement d'avoir ce service au
plus près d'eux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors nous sommes toujours en compagnie
de monsieur jean baptiste à monique vice
président de saint quentin en yvelines
et délégué aux transports et aux
mobilités durables on associe souvent le
vélo pistes cyclables et pourtant force
est de constater que les trottinettes
prennent une place de plus en plus
importante dans le paysage urbain est ce
que c'est le cas ici aussi à saint
quentin en yvelines c'est vrai d'abord
les trottinettes on les a surtout
rencontré dans les grandes métropoles et
on a décidé à saint-quentin-en-yvelines
de mener la première expérimentation de
trottinette sur un territoire périurbain
sur l'ensemble des douze communes
effectivement on a commencé par une
flotte de mille engins avec l'opérateur
tire plus de 300 stations et aujourd'hui
les résultats sont là puisque cette
mobilité du quotidien qui est souple qui
est propre qui est innovante permet de
réaliser les premiers et derniers
kilomètres d'un trajets plus longs
notamment pour rejoindre une gare
routière ou une gare ferroviaire et donc
évidemment qu'on va continuer et
justement s comment s'articulent les
modes de transport ici ce qu'on peut
parler d'intermodalité aussi bien centre
ville que dans les espaces plus ruraux
oui tout à fait l'idée je le disais
c'est que avec nos sept gares
ferroviaires et nos 80 lignes de bus
l'idée c'est évidemment de réduire
progressivement la part modale de la
voiture et d'augmenter celle des
mobilités douces des mots des actifs et
donc aujourd'hui avec le vélo avec la
trottinette on a des solutions de
mobilité qui sont partie prenante de
notre plan local de déplacement que nous
avons depuis 2014 qui nous permettent et
bien de rejoindre d'autres transports
que sont le bus le train c'est des
solutions souples et c'est des solutions
qui aujourd'hui permettent de nous
engager dans une mobilité je le disais
aussi beaucoup plus sobre et qui
répondent aux besoins des saint
quentinois sur l'ensemble des douze
communes puisque toutes les communes
n'ont pas la même typologie on a le
coeur urbain comme ici à montigny on a
des communes qui sont un peu plus
rurales comme ça peut être le cas magny
les hameaux à villepreux alors que ce
soit les trottinettes ou les vélos on a
besoin d'infrastructures tels que des
pistes cyclables ou on est
l'agglomération sur ce sujet
effectivement pour les mods actifs pour
les modes doux comme la trottinette ou
le vélo l'essentiel c'est que les
utilisateurs soient en sécurité et qu'il
y ait des continuités sur l'ensemble du
territoire c'est la raison pour laquelle
en plus des 15 120 km d'itinéraires
cyclables que nous avons sur
l'agglomération nous avons décidé de
lancer le nouveau schéma directeur
cyclable ses 246 km de nouveaux
itinéraires ou réhabilités rénové c'est
un grand plan c un plan d'investissement
de 37 millions d'euros sur dix ans avec
neuf lignes structurantes qui vont
pouvoir venir irriguer l'ensemble du
territoire de l'agglomération
et puis une ambition qu'il faut rappeler
passer d'une part modale vélo qui est
aujourd'hui d'environ 3 % à 8 % et
justement je vous propose de jeter un
oeil sur ce schéma directeur cyclable
le chemin directeur cyclable de saint
quentin c'est un investissement pour les
collectivités de 36,6 millions d'euros
sur dix ans et le travail s'effectuera
sur environ 250 km d'aménagements
cyclables ou accessible aux vélos
c'est un schéma qui est connecté à un
projet régional
vélo qui s'appelle le réseau express
régional vélo ou rer v dont deux tracés
parcourent le territoire de part en part
donc ce sera les deux axes forts de
notre propre schéma le reste du schéma
directeur le reste des infrastructures
cyclables vont permettre un rabattement
verser une forte pour permettre des
déplacements plus longs à vélo et
compris des déplacements de transit de
part en part du territoire
l'articulation aussi à retenir c'est
celle avec le projet de trottinettes
puisque saint quentin en yvelines à
travers le prestataire tirah a lancé un
projet de cantine est en libre service
et l'idée c'est aussi de faire émerger
comme des micropole de mobilité
stationnement trottinette et
stationnement vélo et d'avoir comme ça
une visibilité des baux d'actifs sur le
territoire donc de les rendre attractifs
donc utiliser tout ce travail là vise en
fait à essayer de doubler la part modale
mode actif sur le territoire pour les
déplacements du quotidiens domicile
travail pour arriver à un chiffre
compris entre 6 et 8% ce qui est en deçà
certaines grandes métropoles mais qui
est dans le territoire que
qui à saint quentin et venez déjà serait
déjà une avancée majeure pour les
déplacements du quotidien
jean baptiste à monique quels sont les
publics visés par ces politiques de vélo
et ses modes de transport durables alors
pour le vélo tout le monde de 7 à 77 ans
pour les trottinettes on a évidemment
plutôt cibler les jeunes les étudiants
et jeunes actifs vous savez saint
quentin en yvelines et riche d'un tissu
économique justement très fort et on a
envie de le préserver de la compagnie et
c'est notamment tout l'objet des plans
de mobilité inter entreprises qui
aujourd'hui regroupe plus d'une
trentaine d'entreprises sur le
territoire de l'agglomération
et donc grâce à ces plans de mobilité
inter entreprises on accompagne on
avance on essaye de trouver toujours des
solutions de mobilité pour les salariés
au quotidien que ce soit sur
l'autopartage que ce soit sur les bornes
électriques et que ce soit sur le vélo
est justement c'était mieux je vous
propose de les découvrir en images
le plan de mobilité interne entreprise
de saint quentin c'est une démarche qui
a plus de 10 ans menée en lien avec la
chambre de commerce et d'industrie de
versailles yvelines et l'association
d'entreprises des menaces qui qui permet
des échanges entre l'agglomération et
les entreprises pour faciliter la
mobilité domicile travail et
professionnelle des salariés des
entreprises de cinquante ans
[Musique]
par exemple à 475 on a rajouté des
courses supplémentaires ce qui a attiré
des salariés supplémentaires ce qui du
coup a rempli les buts si on a pu comme
ça a ajouté des courses et aujourd'hui
on a un très bon niveau de fréquence
avec des courses qui parlent toutes les
dix minutes depuis paris qui rejoignent
le secteur en heure de pointe on a même
une idée car à deux étages parce qu'en
fait on avait quand même des surcharges
on a réussi à régler ce problème grâce
aux relations qu'on avait avec les
différentes entreprises
ça favorise à la fois le bien-être et la
qualité de vie des salariés et ça permet
de favoriser le recrutement et de fixer
les salariés recrutés également parce
que ils sont pas embêtés par des
contingences matérielles de comment je
fais pour venir au travail tous les
jours par exemple beaucoup de salariés
habitait dans le secteur de houdan on a
travaillé en lien équipe de france
mobilité pour créer une ligne de bus
l'entreprise thalès le vendredi un
certain nombre de salariés sortent à 13
heures il faut qu'on puisse répondre à
ce besoin à ce moment là
on travaille aussi sur tout ce qui est
mobilité innovante la création de bornes
de recharge pour véhicules électriques
le développement de l'autopartage le
covoiturage là où certaines entreprises
proposaient des services internes
désormais on peut aussi covoiturer avec
les salariés de l'entreprise d'à côté
tout le plan de mobilité inter
entreprises ça nous sert à travailler
sur des projets qui sont un peu innovant
des services un peu différente qui nous
permettent de limiter l'utilisation par
un seul conducteur de la voiture
la mobilité ne concerne pas simplement
les salariés mais elle concerne tous les
saint quentinois alors auriez vous des
conseils alors proposé effectivement
pour s'y retrouver dans ce bouquet de
services de mobilité que propose
l'agglomération on a l'âge ans de la
mobilité qui permettent d'informer et de
communiquer sur tous les services que
nous proposons une agence qui va
d'ailleurs bientôt rentrer dans une
nouvelle dimension avec des nouveaux
services qui seront proposés dont un
mobile bus qui parcourra l'ensemble des
communes de l'agglomération justement
pour informer les voyageurs les usagers
et les saint quentinois alors merci jean
baptiste à money merci à vous merci à
vous et à bientôt pour un prochain
numéro de ce qui m'a dit
[Musique]